Ah, dude, my AI rag application freaking
sucks. How do I fix that?
>> Yeah, a lot of the time it's the
question itself. If someone asks a vague
question with zero context, your
retrieval is going to pull garbage. This
is where adding a rewrite step using the
conversation history or even asking a
quick clarifying question fixes half of
your bad answers.
>> Okay, but what about when the query is
actually good?
>> Yeah, I would start with a hybrid
approach. Vector search and keyword
search like BM25 combined. Vector
catches meaning while keyword catches
exact terms like error codes or SKUs
that semantic search typically misses.
>> I keep hearing about metadata. What
about that?
>> Yeah, you can use metadata filtering.
Tag chunks with things like dates or
document types. So a question about 2024
refund policy narrows the pool. So the
chunks come back from 2024 documents.
>> And reranking? Where does that fit in?
>> Mhm, reranking would come after. Hybrid
gives you a wider, messier pool. So a
reranker reads the query against those
candidates and reorders the best chunks
by relevance.
>> Okay, what's the order of operation
then?
>> Yeah, first clean the query, retrieve
with hybrid search, filter and narrow
with metadata, then rerank. Each step
fixes what the last one missed. Follow
and I'll keep you posted.